I'll be pre-testing the spatha sword
I'm looking for the damage that it will
do
Alex Kevin congratulations you guys are
in the third and final round of this
competition all you need to do now is go
home and recreate this iconic weapon
from history
the spada
this is a barbarian sword I mean Conan
seriously I mean they'd better have some
power and some cutting damage because
it's got a lot to live up to the spata
was a vicious sword given to infantry
during the Roman Empire the double-edged
weapon was used to inflict deep slashes
and deadly cuts on their enemies while
the taper tip was effective for
thrusting in the third and fourth
Century some of these Roman soldiers
turned sides and became barbarians they
then used the spot then Wars against the
Roman Empire and eventually led to its
demise ancient Rome continues to be the
backdrop for Blockbuster films Like
Gladiator in which the spot that can be
seen wielded in battle
Dave's father is sharp strong and it's
well balanced and that's the whole thing
I really am looking about a sword is
when I pick it up am I going to be
controlling the sword or is the sword
going to be controlling me I should be
the one to control the sword and say
you're going here because I say so I
suppose you're too heavier pulling me
that way or this way
blade Smiths welcome back to the forge
you fellas vet four days at your home
for just to work on your finale spotless
Alex how did it go I definitely managed
to find my fair share of challenges but
went pretty well
my blade is about a 50 layer Damascus
steel out of sk5 and 15n20 with a
wrought iron guard and pommel inset and
I've got iron wood garden pommel with a
black wood handle
Kevin tell us a little bit about your
blade
I made a blade out of 5160 and I made a
palm out of brass sandwiched with
Rosewood and then I used tagua nuts to
make it look like ivory a lot of bronze
stand sort of stuff nice that's where
it's got that red appearance it does
when I'm using the spot I'm looking for
the damage that it will do the kill test
is a collaboration between me and the
director so the first one
you want to cut right here test The Edge
on that on a hard piece
cut it through right
on the thrust dead on Center yes
a slow twist your your you know you're
ripping all the guts ripping it out okay
during the pretest with Dave's weapon
I'm able to gauge what to expect
can we try again what's the balance
point of the weapon how can one person
move
is it too heavy where one shot I gotta
recover every time or it's a weapon
that's as I'm cutting and moving around
I'm able to do so in a functional way
foreign
by the time we make it to the
competitor's weapons I have an idea of
what's supposed to do all right please
your spot of swords look amazing it's
time to find out what kind of lethal
damage they can do to do that I will
take your weapon deliver some killing
slashes and blows on this more than
willing ballistics dummies Alex you're
up first you ready for this let's do it
laughs
all right Alex first stop I can really
appreciate the beauty that you have with
your Damascus pattern right there it
really stands out
very clean lines the medial Ridge you
have on here I can imagine how much work
that takes to get it almost perfectly
straight all the way through to the tip
your tip is sharp enough to penetrate
with the thrust and last weight on the
way out and most importantly it will
kill thank you good job
all right Gavin's your turn so you ready
hell yeah let's do this
Alex's uh spot that just destroyed that
uh ballistics Tommy and now I'm feeling
anxious excited
so I got the adrenaline going
doesn't matter
no medial Ridge on either side of the
blade it's one of the parameters right
foreign
your blade Must Fall within our
parameters in order to be tested evenly
and fairly with your competitors your
blade does not have a central Ridge that
was a parameter that was outlined before
we ever sent you home and for that
reason you cannot be the forged and fire
Champion come on my friend
you know it's just a bummer I can't see
a test that's what I really want to see
I want to see how it holds up nice work
on that head thank you I appreciate it
when I was making it it had the defined
Regina just with the sanding and
grinding it just took more of it off but
uh this whole experience has been a
blast congratulations this isn't a loss
I'm coming home with a ten thousand
dollar experience
Alex you made a sharp and deadly spatha
but not only that you made something
that is detailed and beautiful your
attention to detail has elevated you to
the title of forged and fire Champion
congratulations your title comes with a
check for ten thousand dollars good job
brother
this is pretty wild I came here to
challenge myself and put myself through
a super rigorous test and I came out on
top and it feels great it's ten thousand
dollars I'm actually gonna give it all
straight to my parents they supported me
through college as I was learning blade
smithing and they're both getting ready
to retire so that's all going to them